The Joe Rogan experience,
I think it would change the consciousness period.
I think human beings would develop a completely different sense of reality
itself,
completely different cells of our perspective in the universe.
I think it's terms that I didn't mind expanding.
I didn't get one.
Probably took a small dose.
How much do I need to take?
Five grams usually in darkness.
If you can get an isolation tank,
go that way.
Don't be a pussy.
If you're talking about mushrooms and you haven't gotten the big route.
I haven't,
you know,
you've dipped your toes in the water.
You haven't jumped into the ocean.
Can I tell you my mushroom story?
It's pretty funny.
Yeah.
With some friends we went camping,
we were doing mushrooms and uh,
we're all standing in this lake in Idaho,
uh,
with some redneck families camping all around us and we're like two gay guys and
straight go straight.
Couple and were just tripping out of our minds are mushrooms that we're
standing.
It's like in these fish are nibbling or the hairs on her legs and we're all
like,
whoa.
And then suddenly there's a boat going back and forth in front of us that has
dare the drug resistance education logo,
that's the police boat that's going back and forth in front of us.
And then a prop airplane comes right at us.
We're like standing there and this airplane is like,
we see it in the sky,
it's getting lower and lower.
It's pointed right at us.
It comes over right at us at the boat.
And we were all like,
are we see?
Are you seeing each other?
And then the airplane went right over our heads and we all shit ourselves.
We were terrified.
We look how with the fucking disappeared like right behind us on this little
rise.
And we're like,
what the fuck?
And we ran up there thinking it was going to be a plane crash and there is a
runway we didn't see because we've come down to the beach sideways and along the
sand.
And there was an airport right there.
But there was this moment where like we're tripping,
the fish are eating us the dare boats going like this,
which is making us paranoid.
And now here comes the plane for our heads and have done mushroom sentence and
maybe that's why.
Yeah,
that's probably a bad place to do mushrooms.
Set and setting is one of the most important thing as well where you were on a
boat with a fucking dare boat going by and a plane flying and you're at a runway
and we had no idea.
We were standing at the foot of a runner.
Yeah,
you can smoke pot and do Jujitsu with no problem whatsoever.
No problem.
Small pot.
And you're very coordinated.
Smoke Pot and something drops.
You catch it.
Like your reflex is everything.
They're all there and it lasts.
You're not used to it if you're not used to it all you're thinking of.
I remember when I first started getting high,
joey started making fun of me because we,
I forget what we did.
We.
Oh,
I remember we went to um,
the fucking Sunday brunch at a house of Blues.
Remember they had that Gospel Brunch and then that Gospel brunch chest,
that's how we all went over there.
We all went over there and we were toasted to the gills.
It was like one of the first weekends I ever got high and Joey d is like,
look at this fucking rookie and I was going,
I can't believe a high.
Um,
right now this is ridiculous.
I can't,
I have to sit here.
I wasn't used to it.
I didn't know how to deal with it,
but if I was the same high right now,
I'd be fine because I know what that is.
It's,
it's what you're doing is when you're too high and you're paranoid and you're
frozen,
you're frozen because you don't know what it is.
You don't know what,
what comes next because this is going to get worse.
I'm not going to get more crazy.
It was,
oh my God,
how long is this going to last?
But when you're used to being high,
I'm just high dude.
Relax.
Everything's fine.
You know what it is.
He knows the worst it gets,
you know,
the best it gets.
You felt the full,
the full range of the effects.
But you were laughing at me.
I'll never forget.
He like,
look,
it is fucking rookie.
I agree with what you first get high.
You get so enjoyably agree and joy like the symbolic,
a peanut butter and Jelly Sandwich is fucking Philemon and your mouth and you
eat it with a bag of chips when your senses right.
Yet I just said it's.
It's so you don't even breathe.
You're just chewing like I have a giggling like I love to giggle pro.
A couple of weeks ago I had a cookie and I was sitting there as so fucking
stoned at 8:00 at night and I kept thinking to myself,
this is the same cookie KCC case of eight.
It was the weekend.
It was the week that he was busy that he went ms dot.
He died or something.
I felt so bad.
I grew up on fucking Casey case,
but then there was traffic.
I was watching the news that day.
There was traffic on the four,
oh five.
And I'm like,
oh my God,
this traffic on the four or five,
they'll listen.
They said that the cause of the traffic was at the president of Israel was the
four or and I have with thinking about was the president of Israel knows about
these cookies.
Cookie Casey case of he's covered to la to get these cookies.
That's how I was.
I kept giggling at the thought of my thoughts.
That's hilarious.
Was happy and I love that.
I love still giggling.
That's what I miss the most about being stolen to Gill's.
Go to a diner.
The waitress,
just gay boy.
You just fucking.
You can't control yourself like this.
All that shit.
The simple pleasures.
Even before,
like I surprised myself that I became a world champion and kickboxing.
I just wanted to fight to validate my coaching and I just kept winning fights
like,
oh,
I guess I'm all right at this,
but at the end of the day I'm still the biggest fan.
Like I,
I,
you're going to have to kick me out of here today.
I could just keep.
You want to look at more fights.
Like I can watch it till the cows come home with a man
that's,
you know,
that's why I don't watch other sports because I think we're in the coolest
sport.
There's,
you know what?
The two oldest sports on the planet are wrestling?
No fighting and runners.
Oh,
either run.
Not The be food or run to get your food,
rather fight not to be food fight.
They're the two most primal things you can do.
Yeah.
Especially fighting.
I mean,
that's what this kinda kind of,
um,
it's uh,
cicero quote on my arm,
the best protector of the sheep is the wolf.
I believe that some people in there wolves and some people are sheep.
You know,
people love fighting there.
The wolves,
they're the protector,
so you know,
and it's Kinda like training days,
talking about it takes a wolf,
the,
a wolf.
But like fighting is dude,
it's the most primal thing.
I'm still miss that.
That dude wants to kick my ass.
I got to kick his ass.
It's,
it's the most nerve wracking.
It's like a.
all right.
So I was a little experimental when I was a child and teenager after I lost my
sister,
I saw about 25 or 26 grateful dead concerts.
And I,
I'll use this analogy.
I'd say that I'm
fighting your first fight if you've never done it before,
it's like taking acid.
Either find yourself or lose yourself.
I've seen people are the baddest ass person on the planet,
they're the best fighter in the gym and they go to the fight and they just melt
like butter.
They're just can't,
you know,
it's like they trip out,
and I.
that's what I love about fighting you gotta take who you are in that in the gym
and you're a God in front of 20 people and I'll do it in front of 20,000 people
or in a local show,
do it in front of 2100 people.
It still,
I love that vortex,
that rush of improving ground,
true proven ground.
An exposure of truth like nothing else because that's what I think it's like
I've seen so many people lose themselves.